nous sommes au marché de noël de
l'assomption dans lanaudière
un bon marché de noël par une belle
soirée froide d'hiver avec un peu de
neige qui est tombée juste à temps
leslie chesterman bonjour en général
vous êtes chroniqueuse gastronomique on
vous entend l'émission ici sur ici
première ici du côté de chez catherine
chez catherine perrin pleinement le
dimanche après midi
le sport c'est toujours agréable de vous
écouter comment on planifie donc les
repas parce que c'est compliqué dans le
temps des fêtes comment on prévoit nos
dépenses quand il ya plusieurs personnes
à table un temps des fêtes est ce que
c'est le moment de dépenser plus
d'impressionner la visite alors ça
dépend il ya combien de personnes à
table et ça dépend à quel point les gens
autour de nous sont des gastronomes
alors s'il ya vingt personnes à table
c'est pas le moment de sortir les grands
vins c'est pas le moment de servir du
rosbif parce que ça coûte une fortune et
c'est vraiment pas le moment aussi de
faire un plat comme de foie gras parce
que les gens sont vont être en train de
discuter au lieu de parler d'eux est ce
que le foie gras et bien saisi mais si
on est quatre ou six pour noël le cil
moment de peut-être prendre un bon vin
parce qu'après tout c'est noël ou
injuste une autre fête de famille si ces
moments que peut-être si on va dépenser
une fois de l'année ça va être à noël
alors c'est le moment pour ces cinq
minutes par salle on peut commencer à
avoir quelque chose d'extravagant
mais si la famille la boîte de 20 ses
parfums bas c'est sûr parce que c'est
c'est le vini vous avez dit vous avez
jusque là pas mal oui mais donc si on
est beaucoup autour de la table ça donne
rien de trop dépassé parce que dans le
fond on va parler on va s'amuser on va
fêter on attend 180 distraction la
traditionnelle dingue ça demeure quand
même là là
la pièce privilégiée surtout si on
l'achète cette semaine ça va être moins
cher dans beaucoup de supermarchés que
la semaine prochaine
le canard aussi est moins cher cette
semaine que la semaine prochaine il ya
des affaires à faire si on regarde les
des clients c'est la semaine de les
regarder le saumon fumé moins cher cette
semaine que la semaine prochaine et on
peut prendre c'est d'avancer il ya des
choses qui sont congelés ça va être
aussi bons les semaines foi de leur pur
8 à 10 personnes j'achète une dance et
combien c'est en dessous de 40 dollars
en ce moment oui bah oui ça dépense et
il faut un peu faire les le magasinage
pour voir qu'on peut trouver mais pour
ce prix là je suis plus on avait des
crises aussi la dance et aux dix huit à
dix matches et c'est pas loin de 20
parce que on fait on peut manger deux
pommes à la dinde on mange le jour même
ou le lendemain mais on fait un parti
d'inde après la 3e journée
ok ça va très loin des de la soupe oui
pour manger longtemps on peut astuces du
boeuf et d'autres sortes de viandes
également mieux ça devient plus
dispendieux la viande c'est le luxe
maintenant le veau c'est le luxe super
luxe et un autre item qui est vraiment
le luxe n'était pas le luxe avant c'est
le poisson le flétan coûte très cher un
saumon bio coûtent deux fois le prix
qu'un saumon d'élevage normal alors là
c'est rendu que le poisson c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup qu'est ce que
vous pensez de se faire un pote loc1 les
bons mots là pour dire tout le monde
apporte des plots final oui alors le
poste ne peut être un désastre où ça
peut être la même chose au monde mais
mon idée c'est que la personne qui
reçoit va faire la grosse pièce de
peut-être de viande et moi j'aime l'idée
de dire aux gens de la famille qu'est ce
qu'ils vont amener jusqu'à point de dire
je vous envoie la recette
oui parce que comme ça on est sûr qu'ils
reparlent lui-même d'assaisonnement dans
tous les plats c'est pas tout le monde
qui va faire du brocoli ou des carottes
des choux de bruxelles et peut-être une
façon d'aider les gens qui sabotent pas
vraiment faire la cuisine de renvoyer
peut-être la recette pour les aider en
quoi il faut orchestré ne pottoks aussi
claires pour planifier qui s'entraîne on
en finissait prête vraiment aider à ce
que j'ai vécu c'est
est-ce que
si on veut se faire plaisir on dit qu'on
veut aller vers un report c'est un repas
spécial qu'on fait donc un peu plus
luxueux de la zone mais les huîtres qui
sont plus chers que disons les moules
alors si on veut aller dans les fruits
de mer les palourdes ou si c'est un
choix mais c'est c'est toujours dans le
budget parce que les huit ça peut être
très cher même
moi je dis tout le temps si vous n'avez
pas quelqu'un d'autre dans la famille
vous dans votre entourage qui sait
ouvrir les huîtres ou et oublient les
huit ans que j'ai gâché ce l'idée est
bonne mais larié et on peut les acheter
déjà ouvert des fois on peut demander d'
avance ils vont les ouvrir pas trop
longtemps d'avancé mais c'est un option
ça prend le petit couteau également pour
les ouvriers salve de critiques il les
soixante ans de prison c'est peut-être
des vidéos youtube que vous pourriez
regarder pour les huit c'est bon c'est
sûr que si on est un petit groupe qui on
aime le foie gras c'est un produit
québécois alors c'est merveilleux on
peut l'acheter tout fait c'est très cher
mais acheter un peu parce que juste un
peu de foie gras ça va être très lourd
ça va très loin on veut pas trop de foie
gras non plus on peut aussi acheter des
plats préparés chez un traiteur qu'est
ce que vous en pensez de ça mais pour
moi si on achète des plats chez le
traiteur peut-être quelques plats
si on prend tout le repas ça va coûter
très cher et à la fin on va manger du
réchauffé le traiteur veut nous aider à
faire du réchauffé mais peut-être une
option c'est laden c'est pas si
difficile que ça à faire d'acheter la
yam n d'éden qui sont complètement
congelé avec la farce de dar je trouve
au moins on va manger chaud au lieu de
manger réchauffer d'accord d'accord le
dessert on le fait on l'achète
on le fait pour les enfants on l'achète
pour les autres quand c'est la même
histoire que si on est des gastronomes
on veut acheter une bûche d'un grand
pâtissier mais ça va nous coûter environ
en 45 peut-être jusqu'à 60 $ pour une
bûche les huit personnes et des bûches
moins cher que sur travail absolument
débile il ya même une bûche glacée de la
compagnie québécoise quoi tu quoque je
croise et 6 $ et on veut prendre la
bûche et la re décorer de notre façon la
crème glacée coaticook
oui et on peut mettre la crème fouettée
dessus on peut acheter des petites
figurines en pâte d'amande
alors la moitié déjà fait pour nous mais
dans l'est dans l'île dans les familles
québécoises et beaucoup de gens qui ont
la bûche de la famille de la grand-mère
l'a vu quelqu'un qui veulent faire la
bûche il faut les laisser faire la bûche
pour faire plaisir aux enfants on fait
quoi au même table à côté on est parfois
des taties trop longtemps parce qu'ils
ont pas souvent envie d'être là londres
à nous de les jouer
moi j'ai dit que je suis ce qu'on veut
pas dire une maquette de bec macaronis
fromage mais on peut mettre mes légumes
et on peut même le décor et il faut pas
nécessairement faire quelque chose de
gros trop sophistiqué pour les enfants
non plus parce qu'il veut juste jouer
pour ouvrir le cadeau est célébrée non
c'est pas le moment de faire quelque
chose trop compliqué ma nièce et vegan
aux démons que carnivores oui comment je
suis alors on fait beaucoup de plats
d'accompagnement alors c'est c'est sûr
qui fait qu'il faut qu'on accepte
l'autre et que batlles veut manger des
choux de bruxelles et peut-être pas
juste des chutes bruxelles qui sont
juste avec du beurre mais un peu plus
compliquée et elle pourrait manger
plusieurs légumes dans l'assiette et le
seul l la viande de côté et on peut
faire des sauces des gan alors elle peut
avoir un plat de légumes avec une sauce
comme genre de grève mais vegan c'est
très bon vous avez apporté des belles
choses oui des lignes alors ça c'est
tellement ça c'est un classique keats
est tellement jolie c'est des petits
blini on peut les acheter tout fait
avant oui c'est du saumon fumé qui
viennent gaspésie juste avec un peu de
crème de fromage à la crème ou de la
crème sur un peu d'aneth juste une
tranche d'oignons si on veut et je vous
dire ici il y en a pour 5 $ de saumon
fumé saumon fumé c'est cher mais un peu
votre
loin est intéressant et ça il y en a 12
alors ça peut être très bon au début
pour 6 personnes pour une entrevue parce
qu'il faut pas non plus gagner nos
invités plein canapé avant le repas et
vous avez apporté un mousseux alors là
c'est un outil intéressant c'est un
mousseux domaine des berges ville qui
est québécois pour une moitié frontenac
gris moitié ces dix hybride québécoise
qui bat ye frontenac blanc et 12 points
5 % d'alcool s'est pas trop alcoolisés
et c'est une très bonne idée pour
inviter les gens et ça va très bien je
veux apporter 12
on a deux mers nouveau pour tout le
monde si je comprends bien mais on n'a
plus que deux verres on va commencer
avec nous on va commencer avec deux
heures et c'est tellement facile à faire
sa dernière minute
au sam m on demande des enfants de le
faire avec nous ça fait quand même pas
mal de mousse au pays fait froid oui
c'est la fz6 le froid qu'il fait c'est
ça c'est ça c'est fantastique je vous
souhaite de joyeuses fêtes reste un
joyeux noël une bonne année merci
beaucoup c'est un trajet en bus et
goûtez voir si oui c'est bon très très
bon leslie chairman merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci bien